good evening
and welcome to this central area
planning committee
on wednesday the 28th of july my name is
councillor michael edwards
and i'm chairman of this committee
before we commence the business of the
meeting there are a few housekeeping
issues to run through
the setup for the meeting has been
designed to mitigate
for covid therefore can i ask all
president to work to the protocols
agreed
at cancer on 29th of april 2021
in the interests of membrane officer
safety
we are streaming this meeting live as
well as recording
and by being present in the meeting you
are giving your consent to be recorded
members and officers during each item
please put your hand up
and to indicate if you wish to speak i
will then invite you at the appropriate
time
when invited to speak please remove your
mask
put on your visor or turn on your
microphone and speak clearly
please reference the page or paragraph
number when referring to the agenda
papers
please keep your contributions as clear
unconcise
as possible and ensure your microphones
remain off when not speaking
can i draw your attention to the notices
on the agenda papers
regarding the different levels within
the chamber and advise that the fire
exit
is the door behind this top table i
would like to add one
other notice and that is i would like
to propose that the committee agrees
that i move
item nine twenty one zero zero three
three nine
quest motors to the first item as i have
a few things to say about it
can i have your agreement to do that
please
thank you apologies for absence may have
the apologies please tara
yes thank you chairman apologies to be
received from councillor heard and
councillor hubino thank you chairman
thank you item three it is recommended
that the minutes of the meeting held on
the first of july found on pages seven
to eight are approved as true as a true
and accurate record
i so move do i have a sector for this
motion
thank you council morris can i agree
this
by a cent or take a vote
thank you item for declarations of
interests to disclose the existence and
nature of any disposable
pecuniary interests other than other
peculiar interests
or non-pecuniary interests relating to
items of business
on the agenda having regards to
paragraph 6 and inclusive of the code of
conduct for members
members are reminded that they're also
required to disclose any such interests
as soon as they become aware
should the needs arise throughout this
meeting
thank you chair um sorry i haven't got a
visa here actually
uh do you want me to continue to sit or
stand
that's it thank you first of all
uh my disclosure relates to item eight
on the agenda
um although i realize you've shuffled
the agenda but item eight as it is on
the paper on the uh
a published document for silver street
it's been suggested by a resident of
silver street that i have a
close personal relationship with the
applicant
uh i don't i am acquainted with the
applicant
and i know the building but then i'm
acquainted with a lot of people in
malden
and i know a lot of historic buildings
in malden
i've spoken to the monitoring officer
about this accusation
and the monitoring officer has said that
not only do i not have a peculiary
interest
but i don't have a non-pecuniary
interest but in the um
in the uh reason of transparency
i felt it best to declare that i am
acquainted with the applicant
thank you very much thank you
thanks for lagging thanks chair probably
a bit bit um deep
but i better declare a non-procured
interest in agenda writing five because
i have
eaten at the restaurant concerned
[Laughter]
thank you very nice thank you
any others no okay thank you okay then
we'll remove one and move on to item
five which is the um
item i asked to be removed now the
reason i asked this to be moved is
uh because i would like to propose to
this committee
to defer this application and the reason
i want to defer this
application is because we first had doc
uh papers from
officers recommending and then yesterday
we had
amended documents refusing now
i think this is unfair for the applicant
to receive such late information in fact
the day before this meeting
so in fairness to them
i would like to defer this application
to the next committee meeting so that
they
can um
resolve the issue that's been raised
i'll come to you in a minute councilman
uh so they have time to resolve this
issue
because this was unexpected and
i think if i can ask mr johnson just to
elaborate a little bit more
please thank you chairman
well it's really just um going over what
you've said
this application was recommended for
approval on the basis
that a way forward on unresolved parking
base sizes
and lorry parking issues would be
resolved
by the time the application was heard
tonight
it has however transpired that the
matters could not be resolved in time
and as a result it was necessary to
change the recommendation to one of a
refusal of planning permission
on the grounds set out in the members
update
however a view has been taken given the
short notice
of the revised recommendation and the
willingness
of the applicant to seek a resolution to
the parking issues
to request the deferral of the
consideration of this application
to within a time scale which has been
agreed between
officers and the applicant to ensure
that any future decision
as taken by the committee or by
agreement with the chair of this
committee
of this major application does not
prejudice the council's statutory
requirement
to make decisions within government
guidelines for determining planning
applications
thank you chairman thank you mr johnson
and as he said it is a major application
so therefore it needs further
consideration counselor
thank you mr chairman i'd just like to
uh second your proposal on this one
and uh just offer some condolence to the
applicant i don't get emails either
and i'm on the council they don't even
send me emails thank you
thank you councilman so the the proposal
is to defer
do you all agree thank you
so item 21 stroke zero zero three three
nine
sorry councilwoman can i just uh add as
a point for
the officers to look into um i noticed
that and
in 3.2.1 of this application
it said that
arrangement should be agreed prior to
determination
so does that not mean that that has to
be sorted out before it comes back to us
mr johnson
uh i i think if i if i recall
we do have um miss matthews here for
clarification if we need me that um
that matter um has been
has been raised on the members update
am i correct with that miss matthews
yes it's from the update yeah
um one of the updates on the update is
that said have withdrawn their holding
objection on to this proposal
and now i have no objections okay thank
you
so long so okay uh
counter lagging sorry yeah thanks chair
i don't think the resolution's been
passed we've decided to defer it but i
would like to say
a little bit of disappointment that it
brings upon the applicant like
councillor morris has said
because of b3 about parking it's an area
that should have been resolved
by by mutual consent beforehand so you
know i look at that and i think a major
application like this which should be
going
uh before us tonight i have a degree of
disappointment
a bit more plain language would really
help a very simple more than we
understand these things
thank you counseling yes that's been
noted okay
so sorry the proposal was to defer and
we're all greeted by dissent
and secondly by councilman thank you
very much
okay the next item we therefore go on to
item
well it's out of order now slightly so
it's the first one is
2021.0069
which was item five now
269. mcdonald's and this one is
i think catherine matthews is going to
report on that
yes thank you chairman
yeah so this is a adaptation as you say
relating to mcdonald's down on
the full bridge and it involves a number
of um
elements including the reconfiguration
and i say reconfiguration the drive
through lane
so it's got side-by-side ordering and
the parking and the curb lines change to
accommodate that
and there's also some alterations to the
elevations um
of the building including a folded roof
concept
and a small extension and replacement
drive through booths
and we know other minor works including
a little
relocation of the shop front entrance
with the new sliding door
and the installation of two digital
customer order displays
and without the head company can
canopies and a gold post hike restrictor
can anyone hear me okay because
sometimes the visors don't help
right so this is the location plan which
i'm sure most members particularly
councilman lagan is aware of
where it is um aerial
aerial photo and there the car park on
the left hand side is
tesco car park not not the mcdonald's
the mcdonald's
building roughly in the middle with the
um the bypass
um to the northeast
they've got an existing block plan and a
proposed block plan so the
proposed block plan shows the uh the
creation of a second
lane if you like around along one of the
boundaries of the site um
and i've also indicated the positions of
the new custom order
um remember what the d stands for
um the new um displays
and the uh the two new new booth which
will be replacing existing ones on the
eastern elevation
and the position of the new goal post
height restrictor
reference in the report is made to a
2016 application that was approved
which um includes a lot a
number of elements that are included in
the current application including that
second lane along the
western boundary
so we've got existing elevations the
building and proposed so the main
changing
changes being um changing the roof
material
and some um other minor elevation
treatments and the new booths which you
can see on
the bottom left-hand elevation
and existing floor plans probably won't
notice a lot of difference with the
proposed
it's gone proposed floor plans new
booths are there on the on the top
um top
so that's the um customer displays
um and an elevation height restrictor
which is
i'm pretty standard and this is an
example of the roof finish proposed
um
and some photos of bits of the site
various parts of the site elevations of
the existing building which shows the
existing roof materials which would be
changed
and this is a view of mcdonald's from
the nearest um residential property
which is
on the causeway
and view of mcdonald's from the the
bypass which i mentioned earlier with
tesco's in the background
right that's the next one and so
the um proposal is considered to be
acceptable the changes to the site are
relatively minor and also largely
reflect what's what was approved
back in 2016. um there
been no objections to the proposal from
any strategy consorty
and having having been assessed officers
consider the application
is acceptable subject to the imposition
of conditions as set out in your agenda
paper
thank you thank you all right mr
matthews
okay um i would like to
now open the debate and write what any
questions you or comments you might have
uh but i'll perhaps start with the
cancer maze as this is a calling
um councilman's yeah thank you mr
chairman um i was going to give way to
other members first and uh
come back afterwards thank you okay so
councilman morris
very kind of your counselor i just
wanted to know would the
addition of the other lane help
alleviate some of the terrible traffic
congestion that we're experiencing
uh through them and obviously by
increasing the capacity of the site to
store cars while they're waiting to be
served will
inevitably lead to less cars
beyond the site boundaries um
how much that would be um i don't know
but it's
it's quite clearly that that would that
would be the case by having two
two ordering points is going to help the
flow of traffic through the site
and speed it up um compared to what it
is now
could i just disappoint that because yes
thank you for the answer but it may
increase people's appetite to come
because it's a bigger draw because
there's more facilities so we could
actually work in the negative
it's an unanswerable question i suppose
really but it's just a point tonight
okay thank you councilman thank you mr
chairman just a um
useless bit of trivia for the committee
that uh mcdonald's
is the largest toy distributor in the
world
um i personally um
don't like the idea of places like
mcdonald's
uh increasing their strangle hold
on young children's diets and whatever
else
and that dull banging noise that you can
hear in the background is probably mr
lee at home
hitting his laptop because he'll be
saying that this
isn't a planning
thing at all but i
i do not think that morgan district
council should in any way
encourage mcdonald's uh to be
expanding in our district um due to the
unhealthy aspects of the food thank you
thank you council morris
sorry mr johnson
thank you chairman just wanted to draw
some members attention that um
the 2016 application has in fact been
implemented it was approved by uh
committee it has been implemented that's
set up within the report
there are elements on the site that have
already been carried out
so in terms of the implementation of the
two-lane proposal that can actually be
taken place
the the the applicants obviously their
business model had changed
over that period hence the
reconfiguration of certain elements
of this proposal but what members do
have to bear in mind is that this
application has been implemented
thank you chairman okay thank you
councilman
uh yeah thank you mr chairman um yeah
i've looked at this quite carefully i've
also looked at other examples
of mcdonald's drive-throughs with two
lanes
this is one of the smallest well it is
the smallest
that i that i've come across um
i'm very curious as to why the side by
side wasn't
implemented in 2016 and what the
ancillary associated works around the
site that referred to in the report
actually relate to i'm
not entirely happy i like it as it is as
a building it's
it's it's okay i think the dark khaki
green roof is
an excellent choice it will blend much
better with
um the riverside location
however the rather bright gordy cladding
um i don't really understand
i'm not also terribly happy with the um
the fact that there should be 46 car
parking spaces on this site
and there are only 34 that's 12
deficient not one or two
one or two i could have possibly and it
really comes back to what
um councillor lagann was saying about
you know increased cars coming here are
you then you know
you've not only are you increasing cars
you've not even got cars
parking spaces sufficient for the number
of
the spaces that the site should actually
have
um i i did take this up with amit
um patel uh who was very helpful and
provided me
with um a raft of information um
but that's didn't seem to get addressed
this is also in flood zone three uh
which is
um obviously is protected by flood
zoning defenses
can anybody tell me whether it's an a or
a b uh that also
you know it does have an effect should
we be encouraging further development in
a flood zone uh b for example if it's an
a
um that there aren't tests of
vulnerability etc or sequentials or
exceptional tests
yet we apply them elsewhere um perhaps
um
you know you could come back to me on
that the final point i wanted to make
was
mcdonald's seem to have also taken away
the play area
which is now going to be covered with a
piece of road
um and yet i'm not prepared to do
anything to mitigate for that other than
put a few plants in
um i find that wholly unacceptable
um i think that there are there is
demonstrable harm with the
the roof cladding from from an
aesthetics point of view
i don't want this building to stand out
like a sore thumb
uh it's bad enough that we'd have to put
up with the yellow ends
um i'm not uh um i'm not anti
um mcdonald's or anything however i
think there are some very valuable
um things that we need to actually look
at before we take this any further
thank you mr chairman before the officer
makes noise waiting can i just make an
observation on your comments
i think the point of a drive-through is
not to park
so um could i come back mr chairman
um having visited many drive-throughs on
many sites
and not just um mcdonald's not just this
applicant on
lots of other um providers there are
always parking spaces
always i have not been to one that is
literally a drive-through with no
parking spaces unless someone can point
me in the direction
sorry what i meant was that the people
driving in to pick up food will be
driving out again and not actually
parking
i accept what you say but i actually
take issue with it that isn't what
happens in reality
they see a long queue they'll find a
parking space
and they'll walk in okay thank you miss
matthews could answer some of the
questions raised it
why can't
i can address some of them um
in terms of the flood zone and the
sequential tests
um that the assessment because of the
nature of this application and
and the uh the size of the addition
proposed the sequential test um
wouldn't apply anyway um whether they
will be
um so so from the florida's point of
view
it's it's
it's it's acceptable and always no
objection to it
um in terms of the playground if you
removed it
i can understand members concerns and
preference that it would would stay but
um that was put in um
i don't think there's any record of
permission being given for the player to
be put in
and that would have been lost in any
event um if the
2016 application had been implemented
fully um
we i wouldn't know that our officers
wouldn't know the answer as to why the
2016 application wasn't
implemented um without asking the
applicant um which obviously you can't
do
um were there any other questions um
that's what i've got written down
uh yeah i come back to the 46 versus the
34 car parking spaces
and i take it that the flood zone
through you mr chairman um
the flood zone um it's it's because the
site is too small
to make it warrant um any sort of test
sorry i don't understand that's all okay
it's um there's
the the requirements of the um in terms
of flood risk assessment
and and the sequential test it depends
on how big the development
is so where you've got an extension to
existing building if the extension is
below
a certain size then and it's kind of
this under minor development which is
sort of
exempt from the normal rules and
regulations that we would apply
if if for example this the whole
mcdonald's was being applied for now
then it would apply but because it's
only a
small addition to what's already there
then then it doesn't and provided
the floor levels are the same and they
introduce flood
resilience measures which they have then
that satisfies the government
guidance on development in terms of
flood risk
in terms of parking i think that sorry
catherine just
before if members can look at 5.6 of the
report that actually sets it out
and in 5.6.1 that talks specifically
about the
size of the extensions um and the
under thresholds of 250 and in this case
the proposal is for five square meters
so that's set out there
in terms of the the other elements
regarding flubberis
sets out 5.6.293 thank you chairman
thank you can i just comment on what
something that
mrs matthews mentioned i sorry cancer my
mays
mentioned the fact that um why was it
not built when it was approved
i presume that would have been a
business decision rather than a planning
issue yeah i i can uh just just just
respond to that i mean as
i stated earlier um the application has
been implemented in terms that it
started
now although permission was back in
2016. once you once you materially start
the works it means you can sort of
finish it as and whenever
i did mention that there was more likely
a business decision in terms of some of
the configuration
and as set up within the report
the the layout which is currently in
front of you
is the original layout but they had
actually come in with a modified layout
which had a slightly different um
exit from the collection point
that was the basis of uh you know fairly
in-depth highway
comments which led to a removal of that
proposal
and reversion back to the original
proposal so there were some business
decisions which they're taking
during that time which has led to this
position yeah thank you
thank you sorry i think cancer morrison
then um
counts your bill wasn't it yeah
councilman thank you mr chairman i was
just going to
come back to uh councillor mays and just
say that
on occasion uh the causeway and
fallbridge
are all made into a car park by
mcdonald's
um i've been there quite down there
quite a few times and seen
such sort of car parking carnage that i
i don't think that um increasing the
amount of people they can serve is going
to help the
local traffic thank you caterpillar
thank you chairman i can really see this
new layout causing a lot more problems
than what we've got already
as councilor morris said it's absolutely
horrendous down here sometimes unless
there's staff there's stopping traffic
they block it it goes right the traffic
goes right back to the roundabout
it's dangerous and if you're telling me
that
one lane going into two going back into
one is going to increase it or below the
toddle
basically you're going to have arguments
it's going to slow down the queue
because the people on the outside are
going to be trying to get in sorry did
you say cancel
bill but one going into two going to one
that's not the case
one going one into two into one is going
to slow up the whole operation
because the people on the outside
obviously run
right they're gonna they're just gonna
have to keep forcing themself out to get
into the existing queue
that is gonna cause a lot more problems
than what is gonna
benefit
i could cancel buildings can there any
comment
you can on on that miss matthews um
through chairman i was uh i hadn't come
back
um before and talk about that um
to councillor may's question about the
parking and that is set out in the
um report um 5.5.2
and where it says that for food and
drink units which is
what the mcdonald's is and the standards
are set as a maximum of one space for
five square meters
and then there was um so the maximum
spaces would be 46 but 34
spaces is does comply with the
adopted standard i can appreciate
members may have
different views as to whether that would
that's enough for this particular store
but um we're
um business but uh that's the
parking standards that um we're working
with and that have been adopted um in
terms of
um whether the proposal would
make the conditions better or worse
um officer's view is that it
it there's the potential that you could
make it a bit better but it certainly
won't make it any worse
and and therefore and no harm would be
caused by the development proposed in
addition and
even if there is existing harm it won't
make the harmony worse and therefore
there wouldn't be grounds
to refuse the application that could be
could be sustained officers would would
suggest
so um and and and
i think it's been mentioned before at
the meetings that you can't
expect uh development to um
can't require a development to improve
an existing situation
and the planning process would just um
aim to prevent
any problems getting worse than they
than they are
and i think mr lee talks about wiping
wiping their own face
um so um so yeah that was
how i would respond to and those
concerned
thank you counter swain i think you were
next one then cancer morris
thank you yes um
obviously the traffic is the mainstream
as far as flood risk is concerned
can you put the microphone down but i
can't hear you sorry sorry
can you just move the microphone towards
you i can't hear you oh thank you
um yes i mean if this is a flood risk
then the same
risk applies to tesco and it'd be much
more serious if
if that was flooded and um mcdonald's or
something
um as far as traffic is concerned we
have this problem i mean the problem
shows that it wasn't a very good place
or would not
under current circumstances be a very
good place to have a drive through
mcdonald's or perhaps a mcdonald's at
all
um the traffic does back up
and i'm not sure quite whether any we
can
have any sort of a mitigation for that
i was there on last weekend uh it was
lunchtime on
saturday and it was in fact impeding the
roundabout traffic
um one could get around there and but it
they were having to make spaces for it
and that was backing up onto the
roundabout
but that's got that's a problem that
that exists anyway
um i think it is possible that um
the easier throughput will ease that
rather than have the up
alternative effect of just encouraging
more trade
um but when it comes to it if we
um don't allow what is a should we say a
bit an improvement for
their business um we are in fact saying
we're trying to restrict their business
activity
um and i'm not sure whether we really
can do that simply on the grounds of a
problem that is offside
though it's going to be there anyway and
which people needs other
mitigation factors thank you
thank you council uh i think the captain
um just coming back to councillor swain
i think that the um
geographical location and um
the um
size of the building um are going to
restrict it more than
we ever can i would like to propose that
we go against the officer's
recommendation and refuse this one
i'll ask for a second to please
accountable secondly okay sorry
thank you james i just wanted to remind
members that um i said earlier this
application has been implemented
uh the drive-through uh
dual lane is exactly the same as what
was approved in 2016.
um there is nothing to stop them from
carrying out those works
as they currently are um refusing this
application would only
prevent the decorative changes which
they're proposing
and also an extension to the cache and
the presenter booth of the five square
meters which would just
make working conditions uh somewhat
slightly better for the operatives
thank you chairman thank you
yes thank you mr chair if i could just
come back i mean this might well be
a fake accompli but um at the end of the
day it
it it doesn't make a lot of sense to me
i wasn't here in 2016 and i wouldn't
have liked this in 2016.
um we're in 2021 and i don't like this
now
so um a proposal i've got a proposal in
uh thank you very much councillor bill
for second in it um i'd ask that we
could put it to the vote please chair
the proposal um
yes it would have to yep chair um i
would um
cite uh lack of car parking
and flood thank you
council legend you wanted to have a
final word quick
point thank mr johnson for pointing out
and reminding members
members are entitled to debate and have
a view
based on the information that's in front
of them i think when we've looked at
this debate which i think has been very
interesting to consider
um there's some points foreign points
against it
but the fundamental problem with this is
not this development it's all the over
development this place has seen
through terrible decisions of the past
that we can't change so this place is
choking
and this is just an example of that
so i just want to say that thank you i
think we've debated this now
so councilman thank you for the
opportunity to come back
um if this layout was
um agreed in 2016 and they want to
re-implement it
why is it back here why is it back at
this
this planning meeting because that's
what we're trying to agree i don't
understand why it's come back here
for because that's the major part of it
and certainly the bit that we've
spoken about the most why is it back at
this
planning committee and they're not just
implementing it
they can right well the reason why it's
back here because there are a number of
other elements which are material
development to the site that require
planning permission
certainly isn't how the report reads so
sorry i don't
don't get it okay
okay um tara sorry do we have to take
we take you sorry
on the on the first one yes cancer
morrises so cancer morris's
recommendation is to refuse in fact um
seconded by cancer bills so
a show of hands then please
okay so we go back to the original
recommendation which is to approve this
application
so can i have a show of hands please
that's the course
sorry sorry through you mr chairman do
we not have to have somebody actually
propose
that we uh accept this
it's just that there's elements on on on
this plan that that i don't like
okay but i don't i didn't agree with
refusing it on the grounds that
was refused do i have someone to propose
the recommendation please
your proposal okay and the second to
police to countless ways
council like thank you okay so we now
have a private proposal and the
secretary
to approve the recommendation recording
folk please share a recorded vote please
so do you want to call it recording vote
um
goes against
abstentions
i'm sorry but i will approve this thank
you
so 210269 has been approved
item number six
twenty one strike zero zero two seven
zero
sorry mcdonald's again so
um yes thank you chairman so this is one
of two applications um
for advertisements at the mcdonald's to
upgrade and add to the adverts that are
already there so this application is for
the instruction for fascia signs on the
building and
these four would replace existing signs
so there'd be no
additional signs so on the
location plan again so these are the
existing elevations
um and you can see the yellow m's
in various positions and also the word
mcdonald's on the bottom right hand
corner there
on there on the front elevation and then
the proposed elevations
um so the front elevation which is the
bottom right hand corner
that those two signs are replaced by one
large yellow m and a fascia sign and
then we've got replacement some signs on
the other two
on the side elevation as well and
so again these are photos of existing
but that that's
not much more to say on on that one
other than um
the uh the the designs would not cause
any harm in terms of
appearance or or highway safety which is
the two main issues
and to consider when determining
applications for advertisements and
therefore it's been recommended for
approval subject to
condition thank you thank you
um okay open for debate so
council morris thank you mr chairman um
i
would propose that we go against the
officer's uh
recommendation to approve and knock this
one back
i would say that um we do not need to uh
be taking drivers eyes off the road
looking at uh
screens on a building and yet again
um i don't think we need to be
advertising something that is
detrimental
to our young people and people in
general
thank you thank you
councilman uh yeah thank you
um i don't i think we're stuck with the
the yellow m
um i'm not keen at all on the uh
implementation of the white lettering of
mcdonald's
um it's much more intrusive to the eye
than the black is the black sort of
disappears into the background
you see it when you get up a little
closer we all know what the end means
um and i think it's i think it's too
intrusive
thank you thank you councilman
anyone else cancer swag
sorry oh yeah sorry i've missed that one
second that kind of my second occurrence
of monitors proposal cancer swaying
mcdonald's to advertise their
establishment and um
using the logo is a reasonable
substitution
okay thank you anyone else
so the proposal is from council morris
to refuse secondly by cancer in may
so
well
highways and also that it is intrusive
and in congress
yeah um just just to remind members that
the um
the advertisement consent are controlled
strictly by the impact on amenity
and highway safety in terms of the
latter there is no there's no objection
from
highways in terms of highway safety uh i
think given the nature of the site
that's
purely you know self-evident so um
a a reason to refuse on that ground
could not be sustained and in my opinion
my professional opinion
i could not just sustain on any appeal
in terms of the immunity of the area um
just to sort of state the obvious this
is clearly not a conservation area
it is within a commercial setting
and therefore immunity has to be within
that particular context
um there is no immediate impacts in
terms of its juxtaposition against any
sort of residential area or in that
sense
it is an area what it is and it is a
business which is promoting something
which already exists
so hence that's the context for which
officers has made this recommendation
for approval of this application thank
you chairman thank you
yes councilman uh yeah thank you thank
you mr chairman for the
opportunity to come back i don't have a
problem with making the m bigger i don't
have a problem with where they put it
i don't like the white which i believe
is intrusive visually
in the area and i don't think it is
necessary as a result thank you
okay okay so can we
therefore put the proposal to the vote
sorry
[Music]
can you just repeat your um counts for
mace
that the signage is he's visually
intrusive and obviously causing harm
um detrimental to the area
what counselor may said thank you
can i ask for a recorded vote please
chairman
um a four against your selfies when i
call your name
and starting with councilman's bill
thank you cancer edwards abstain
council
that's a lagoon
[Music]
upstairs
[Music]
well i'm sorry but i'm going by the
officer's recommendation
yes
could i just get clarity on that because
you said you're going against the
officer's recommendation but the
recommendation was made by councillor
morrison's proposal
okay yeah
so now we need to vote on the approval
for
the recommendation
proposal cancer swain secondary cancer
bill
taking this as a reported vote again
chairman um members
should indicate four against from stone
please starting councillor miss bill
and this is for approval as per the
officer's recommendation
four thank you councillor edwards
abstain counselor
mays oh um story thank you
sorry i've missed you that's my fault
i've missed cancer council lag and
apologies i've missed you often
um against
facebook okay councilman royce
uh against thank you councillor nunn
councillor seancy abstain
thank you councillor stilts yes
councillor swain four chairman that's
three four
four against two abstain
okay so there we go three four four
against
two obstacles so it's uh
that's lost so this is a uh wild west
situation
so what did we do now we have to
run through the chair through the chair
um ms johnson is there any chance that
we could speak to the applicant and um
come back with something that um
preferably uh
a majority of us could agree to is that
an option that we have
i would say it's not something that i
would advise
um through the chair could um is this
something that we could uh
now take a vote on to defer for central
planning
so basically we defer this put it up to
central
so we all make the decision we are
central councilwoman sorry
district
yes we're not running into a timing
issue at all
i don't know i mean 28-day timing well
again mr johnson
um uh it's something that we would you
know discuss and
and um if the applicant feels that
there's a possibility
that there may be a decision in their
favor then i'm sure they'll be agreeable
to an extension of time
but saying this advert applications
don't actually impact on our performance
as such
in terms of our government stats
so the proposals refer um to refer to
district is that is through a secondary
on that
okay can i have a show our hands if we
do that
and how many is that sorry
before again abstain please when i call
your name this is for deferring the
application to be decided by
the district planning committee starting
with councillor miss field please four
thank you
councillor edwards abstain
thank you uh councillor
logan oh please tara thank you
councillor mays for thank you councillor
morris
four councillor numb councillor shaunicy
four councillor stilts councillor swain
chairman that's six four one against one
abstention
okay so that's now been proved to defer
until a later date thank you
right item number rasama
where are we number
so this is the other um application
which i alluded to earlier and these are
for
some new signs and they're um
they're linked with the proposal to
increase the number of um
driver ordering displays and so we've
got five new
digital freestanding signs and one
digital booth screen
another patient plan and the air review
and that that was
the proposed um layout which has
now been approved so um
you can see this very well but the the
red signs are the new signs
and proposed and then we've got some
signs that have
previously had permission and
and the relocation of previously
approved signs which
were now in the wrong wrong location
because of the change to the layout of
the site
so these are examples of science so this
is a double paneled
um sign cancel out them they might be
getting hungry
and another sign that there's a smaller
one um
of the digital displays
and little um screen at the which will
be at
the booths and again same photos again
of the
the site anymore oh yeah
um of the existing building
so again the same same issues arise them
issues of highway safety and immunity
and the as officers have explained in
the in the report
it's considered that none of these signs
cause
harm to immunity or highway safety and
therefore recommended for
approval subject to conditions thank you
thank you
um okay um open to debate then please
cancel
morris thank you mr chairman um i don't
want to draw out the advice
advertisement for mcdonald's anymore so
i would propose that we defer this to
district council
do i have the second to please
can i just correct me if i'm wrong but
does this not
refer to the first application where you
have to have boots when you have two
drive-ins
as i said this this um they're they're
the this one is is linked to the the
first the planning application that was
uh
considered and and approved um to
the adverts proposed are are to do with
this than the
creating the double lane and increasing
the number of people who can
um order for use for ordering
as you go in the lane is that
so one goes it can't go without the
other surely well
these are these are the they're adverts
so they've got
the menu displayed on them so people can
be
choosing what they want to order when
they get to the order display yes
yeah so it's not advertising as such in
terms of
mcdonald's
it's the menu for people driving in yeah
so they come under the
advertisement regulations but they're
not like the m and the
north side but if you don't have them
there when you drive in you can't order
exactly well is that right it would make
it more difficult yes
okay thank you you've got the addition
because um got the additional two lanes
yes sorry council lincoln was first i
think
lagoon canceling thank you chair
um yeah i think the i think you actually
said it
quite right one goes with the other so
if you have your
your two lanes you're going to speed
people into having
more signage so i don't have a problem
with this at all
i'll be truly honest with you thank you
thank you mr chairman um i'd like just
to point out um
5.3 of the report effects on public
safety and 5.3.1 considerations of
public safety
defined as matters having a bearing on
the safe use and operation
of any form of traffic or transport
including the safety of pedestrians
that is a quite well used pedestrian
area and
whilst having more cars slowly parked up
is fine
i do believe that it would be
detrimental to public safety if you've
got these uh bright screens and
people crawling through traffic whilst
trying to see what's on the
pound saver menu and uh you know running
people over as they
go thank you okay customize
thank you mr chairman um my concern
really
lies around the number uh and always has
been the number of
because it's such a small site uh it
comes down to what
councilor morris was just saying about
when you when you're driving in there is
no reason to have nobody ever looks at
the first two menus
it is always the menu by the actual
booth where you order
um that that uh that you look at
if you're gonna look at one because most
people know what they want
so that that is the element that i'm
unhappy about
i think it is over development within
this very small site
and it is very cramped going through
that and to add
two lanes which has already been agreed
that's fine um
i think actually adding in additional
signage
is unnecessary for this particular site
thank you council again
so just a quick supplementary the thing
and i'm glad members are taking safety
seriously because that's how i earn my
living but one of the things i read
in condition seven was about the
proposed light source of the position
and shielded perpetuity to direct light
towards the proposed advertising side
away from the highway
so the concern which is a valid concern
about highway safety
is would be addressed by that condition
to mitigate that potential harm
so i just wanted to point that out
within the council sorry can i just ask
which
condition are you referring to condition
seven page 34 at the very top
got the wrong one sorry that's right oh
yeah
got it thank you
okay thank you um
yeah i just wanted to just to point out
for mrs matthew just to point out where
the
where the signage is i know you did it
earlier on uh but in terms of
in terms of highway and pedestrian
safety which um councillor
uh moyes mentioned earlier the the
parking area and where most of the
pedestrian footfall
um lies is to the is to the east of the
site
if you could just sort of point that out
with matthews and
just just just wanted to just draw that
out so that when we do consider highway
safety we consider where is the parking
where are the where are the actual
footpaths where people are walking
they tend not to be walking around where
the two lanes are
so just some of the obvious we just
wanted to draw out when we come to these
considerations
thank you so tell you chairman this is
the
now approved um new layout for the site
so you've got the the drive through
lanes on on this side and the
parking area um and then the parking
area is
on the other opposite side of the site
and towards the front of the building
and the signs that are proposed are
along this
um western side of the building where
the ordering points
and yeah the ordering points are and
in advance of them um so
as uh mr johnson suggested there's there
shouldn't
be any pedestrians going down there
there's no need
there's no way for them to go or no
reason for them to go down that side of
the building
um because the entrance to the building
is um for pedestrians is is
on the front and they'll be coming
potentially from the car park to the
front of the building and not not
needing to go in this area here where
the adverts are um are proposed
so um i just don't
consider that there would be that um
issue
and the other point worth noting is that
the um
highway safety um would
normally only be thought about
in in detail to do with the public roads
rather than on private land
and and the responsibility for making
sure that
um people pedestrians are safe on
private land will be with the what the
owner rather than
on public land where there's a more
public responsibility and duty to make
sure that things are safe
well the layout of areas are is safe
for pedestrians and or other road users
to use thank you
thank you council morris um thank you mr
chairman whilst i thank
mr johnson and miss matthews
for pointing that out um we have spent
well mcdonald's has spent
um at least a couple of years now uh
getting
children used to running that way for
the um
uh playground that they will be
tarmacking over
so uh you know that that has got to be a
consideration
these um bright screens that take
drivers eyes off the road
and what they're doing um i'm not a fan
i'm not a fan of them at all
um and um i point to the proposal that i
put to earlier sir
thank you thank you okay
yeah um i just wanted to point out to
members that
it's actually the location of where
these um
boards are the two existing if you look
at the
uh the top screen um you've got one car
right at the top you've then got two
cars which are going through
the next two cars are the ones that will
have
the screens where you order fine okay
that's
not a problem you'll then have where the
next two cars are there'll be one on the
corner there
and then one on the left hand side as
well now from my and then
one further on back in the
bit that you go up i just feel that
because this site is
extremely small and it is one of the
smallest in the county
if not the smallest that i've come
across i can't find a smaller one
but it is too much development for this
site
just it's over development thank you mr
chairman
thank you thank you
um yes thank you um on the question of
pedestrians and
people do pedestrians do go there i
assume that
the the serving facilities for
pedestrians are
separate and therefore there shouldn't
be any mixing with traffic
however um there is and quite rightly
the
question of having adequate pathways
protected
within the areas is mcdonald's problem
um but but people do cross um
people who come from that area and they
go into the tesco
uh car park where they may have stayed
or they
may be going there to take their food
and i think that is the
area where the the pedestrian risk is
but that is actually i suppose on the
entrance to tesco
where they a sort of pseudo zebra
crossing
um that's the only risk otherwise it's
uh
an internal problem for um the
circulation within mcdonald's site
thank you council this way so i think we
do we have a proposal
and was deferral to district planning
committee
sorry council morris proposed that the
application be deferred to the district
planning committee yes
and i was seconded by councillor mays ah
recording vote please sir
yes um so this is voting for the
application to be deferred to the
district planning committee
um if you could indicate for against um
or abstain when i call your name please
starting with councillor miss beale
please
i'm staying thank you councillor edwards
abstain
thank you councillor against thank you
councillor mays
four thank you council morris four
councillor nun
councillor seancy abstain council stilts
cancer swain okay so that's two
four chairman four against and three
abstentions
so that's lost so that's lost okay thank
you
so now we go back to
thank you mr chairman um whilst i'm not
in favor of passing this
on the officer's recommendations what i
would like to say is maybe that we
consider
my proposal would be that we refuse this
under visual
clutter and over
development of the advertisement
sites seconded
is that a consideration yeah
okay
for a um as indicated by councillor
stilts if you could just indicate
forward against your staying please
start in the council atmosphere please
understand okay councillor edwards
four councillor against
cancer mays or casa morris
four councillor councillor
four cancer stilts cancer
thank you so that's failed on the
grounds up
what's described the um
the reasons given were visual clutter
and over development of the
advertisement sites
thank you
i item number
i've lost a little bit
eight twenty one stroke zero zero two
nine seven
silver street can i ask um who is
talking on this
thank you
can i have the officer report please
when you
oh sorry report first yes
firstly please note the members update
with an additional condition
regarding details of the ventilation
unit to be provided
prior to its installation
number four silver street is a timber
frame property with a rendered frontage
with the earliest parts dating from
circa 1400
the proposal relates to various internal
and external works which are outlined in
detail in the report
but include the rearrangement of the
internal layout
an additional staircase new lime creek
floor
replacing the flooring in the cellar a
ventilation system
the removal of the carport the removal
of the
rear conservatory and replacement with a
canopy
the removal of a small northern
projection
and alterations to the fenestration
it's important to note that the proposal
is for the work stated
only and not for any change of use of
the site
any change of use would require planning
permission under a further application
and is outside of the scope of the
current application and should not form
part of the decision-making process
this is the location plan showing the
site outlined in red
off of silver street to the north of the
high street
this is the existing and proposed site
plan
the existing proposed north elevations
showing the removal of the cart lodge
the side projection and the alterations
to the fenestration
which includes the replacement of most
of the windows
the existing and proposed south
elevations
showing the removal of the conservatory
installation of the covered area
and again alterations to the
fenestration
the existing and proposed east elevation
plans showing again the removal of the
conservatory
and changes to the windows
the existing and proposed west
elevations showing the removal of the
carport
and the gates to be restored to the side
of the property
all of the windows would remain as they
are but would be restored
the existing basement plan
and the proposed basement plan showing
the internal alterations to the seller
the existing ground floor plan
and the proposed ground floor plan
showing the alterations to the
layout and the other alterations
internally
this is the ground floor plan also shows
the
ceiling
and the proposed ground floor plan also
showing the ceiling
the existing first floor plan um showing
there being seven
bedrooms
and the proposed first floor plan
showing it would be reduced to
five bedrooms
uh some sectional drawings of the
dwelling
and some further sectional drawings
some photographs of the street scene and
you can see the
carport to the northern side with the
pitched roof that would be removed
photos of the rear projection on the
left hand side
and then the street scene again on the
right hand side
further photos of the rear elevation
this sort of conservatory
structure to be removed and the north
side elevation
uh some further north and rear elevation
photos
and various internal photos of the
building
overall the proposal is supported by
both historic england and the council's
conservation officer
as being an exemplary proposal for this
listed building being comprehensive and
sensitive in its approach to the
proposed restoration works
it's considered that the proposal would
not result in detrimental harm
to the residential amenity of
neighbouring occupiers the parking
provision at the sites or the provision
of private amenity space
the proposal will also not harm the
character and appearance of the site or
surrounding conservation area
nor will it harm the setting of the
listed building it's therefore
recommended for approval
thank you chairman thank you louise
now we have two public uh
uh one objection one supporter can i ask
first of all
miss wood you have two minutes
if i can remind you on that starting
when you
ready thank you
i'm here as a representative of my
neighbors in silver street cromwell hill
and beeley road
to object to the following planning
applications for grade 2
style listed for silver street we
support the renovations but we strongly
object to the alterations proposed which
are entirely out of proportion
for a residential dwelling external
visual change of appearance
on every elevation demolition of a
lean-to
cart port and breaking through georgian
brick barrel vault sellers to install a
secondary staircase
of galvanized steel the committee report
for approval
opens declaring the reason for listing
of properties in this area
goes deeper than the aesthetically
attractive qualities
and show how they have developed
organically over the centuries
so why do so many of the proposals for
alterations
refer to enhancement and improved
aesthetic appearance
these proposals pick and choose
different parts of the property's
history
according to neatness and symmetry there
is great inconsistency of handling
to the point that no independent
consultant has been
involved with this application historic
england has relied totally on documents
provided by the conservation officer
and the applicant's architect no site
visit to conduct an independent
assessment has been executed
this application has been dishonest in
its approach
the applicant declared at the town
council planning meeting on the first of
june
that four silver street would be an
airbnb with a music venue in the cellar
a change of use application should have
been raised first
then if it failed we would not all be
here on the verge of losing the
integrity
of a heritage building in one of the
last street scenes unchanged for over 50
years
and reflect the recent media publicity
of malden district council's commitment
to preserving heritage assets
thank you very much uh miss wood and can
i now ask mr smythe
if i just remind you you have two
minutes as well please yes thank you
chair
yes i'm here representing the modern
society the committee
of the modern society adds its support
to this application
and the endorsements by several heritage
specialists
in their in their support society
members were given the opportunity to
visit the property and tour it over a
weekend in june
and see the results of the investigatory
works of the applicants being carried
out
they saw some exposed wonderful examples
of medieval timber frame
some georgia modifications that were not
quite so good
and some twentieth twentieth century
editions
that blatantly distracted from the
minute merits of the original building
the remote that there are some very
attractive features in the building that
have been exposed
the removal of the carport the porch
the conservatory the modern windows on
the southern side
all detract from the purity of the
original feature
the extensive scope of the remedial
works and the renovation works is a
credit to the owner
he's retained notable expertise in the
exploration of the building
and they've uncovered a hearth remote
remains of a hanging curtain in a
medieval
hall and knowledge what will
end up as a knowledgeable tribute to the
history and construction
of a grade 2 style listed building we
would add our support and we would urge
you to support both these applications
thank you very much mr smyre okay so can
we start open the debate please
council morris thank you mr sherman um
i've looked at this one
and i've looked at this one again and
then i looked at it again
and i just uh i can't make my mind up on
it
um for that reason um because i'm
usually quite good at
uh um judging these ones i would propose
that we do a site visit
before we uh take anything further there
seems to be a lot of positive stuff
being said about this but also
we can't ignore the amount of um letters
of objection
um i do uh i would ask the rest of the
committee to consider a site visit so
that'll be my proposal
that this will be deferred so a site
visit can take place thank you
thank you do i need a second on that
first of all
catch us honestly sorry sorry
um just in terms of the site i don't
know the answer to this but um
obviously consideration about site visit
to a
dwelling house where obviously there are
external
works that that's pretty straightforward
but it's the internal works
uh particularly developed to the
substance of a lot of the concerns
raised
and how members would need to just
execute that sort of site visit to
ensure that it's
you know within safety regulations
around code et cetera
oh yes it's nothing against that i'm
just sort of raising that that sort of
you know that that sort of that issue of
you're clearly entitled to do that
thank you um
yes please chef yes i would just say
that we need to come up with solutions
and not problems
thank you um
the reason must be clearly set out by
the proposed and recorded
okay is there any further debate on
on cancer swaying i think there were a
lot of things to be said on this
and including this question of um
has been mentioned about um
an outside view an independent view and
we've got the same statements repeated
but they're basically
repeating what um the conservation
officer
has written in the past
and
including english heritage who haven't
looked at the place um so i mean that is
a gap that there has there's no sort of
independent view of
the impact of this impact of all these
changes
um some of which
are producing minimal harm but there are
quite a lot of these
instances where the harm is um
considered acceptable and so on
um and
what i i obviously the um
officer was clarified a position on
fenestration um i wonder whether we'd
have any
view of what this outside canopy thing
at the back would look like i don't
think got any information on that and
they've got a view of it
and i mean
for you chairman i appreciate that is
quite a small
um plan to see um but the
condition three of the listed building
consent would um
require details of full details of the
materials
of all parts of the development to be
submitted and so the finer detailings of
the canopy
and the materials would have to be
submitted prior to its installation
and agreed by the council the
conservation officer and historic
england
thank you chairman i would like to ask
what the impact is on the structure of
the building
of having this so-called protected
corridor um and what the point of that
is
um which would fundamentally change them
i mean they're changing the the nature
of the bedrooms considerably
internally and then this corridor
presumably
running alongside them effectively
separating it from
the main house in a way i don't wonder
what that would have impact on the um
structure of the building mr johnson
would you
can you answer that at all
uh i suppose all i can say in that sense
is that
given the comments from english heritage
and our own conservation officer
the works would actually strengthen and
support the
the actual building rather than sort of
weaken the integrity of it
i mean that's the whole purpose for you
know localized intervention into
elements of the building
and its proposal um so i can't i can't
see how
and also having regard to the comments
that the proposed works
um would detract from the physical
integrity of the building
okay there is a mention when it comes to
this um extra staircase
which again may seems to me partly to
isolate part of the house
but it says the phrase is a suitable
flight could be designed
um i think one would want to have more
detail
it just could be designed um but there
is no design it hasn't been done
there isn't this question of parking
and the fact that it's produ reduced
from 75 bedrooms doesn't seem to matter
because it's more than four bedrooms and
therefore there is a requirement for
three parking spaces of which there are
only
two um i would just
want to point out that um that sort of
parking provision is on this presumption
i think that the residence is used as a
whole family residence if it were used
and it's lacking a parking space even
even at that level
um i mean my overall
view is that if you move into a um
a building of this age and character uh
including some of the more recent ones
which are only a hundred years old
um that you you adapt
yourself to the building to some extent
you don't try and
recreate the building in a to suit a
modern a particular person's lifestyle
or whatever
um so that's um my overall view is that
this is
goes too far in terms of undermining and
damaging the
existing building um well and it's
probably even more
emphasized by the fact that in doing
some of this work they've identified
even
more features that are relevant to its
it's it's history thank you cancer
cancer lagging yeah thank you chair this
is a really
complex making process because it is
such a
emotive building because it's in an
incredibly beautiful part of the town
and what worries me there's two things
that worry me there's a lot of things
that are very positive about it but to
talk about the concerns are
one is that the seller you know i think
council swain's already touched upon
that so i don't need to go over their
old ground on on that aspect of it
and the second one is of and i i have i
have the highest level of regard
for our conservation officer um without
exception
he's one of the best out there but a
desktop report submitted um to make a
decision
on really causes me a tad of concern um
probably a greater
than tad um because of
because of the the nature of the
building and the historic value that it
brings
um so i i'm concerned about the the fact
that
you know we haven't had the ultimate
experts look at this
with their own eyes touch and feel um
and that's without being disrespectful
for
tim in any way shape or form so i
i have so many positives for it but i
also have a
noise in the back of my head saying this
could be demonstrable harm
for the seller and i'd very much like
more
more real high quality expertise to be
involved in this
and i'm not that thank you thank you
can't you honestly
yes thank you chairman i'd like to say
at this point
that i have a huge worry it's not just
for this property but other properties
around the town
that developers are allowed to go in
before
planning permission is granted
now mr house and cannot be there 24 7.
we don't actually know fully what
happens when these people
are in there before planning consent
is granted and
another property within the town in
london road
actually did come a cropper
under this scheme or whatever you call
it
where things were taken out of the
property chimney breasts
fireplaces etc and so
i really think that we need to change
our policy
on this this may not be the right time
to bring it
up but i feel because of this
special property this number four i
think it is the right time
for myself to to bring this up i don't
think people should go
into a property and do anything until
they've had
proper planning permission to do
whatever
you know that they set out that they
want to do
i'd just like to say that chairman thank
you thank you
mr johnson the response i would have
to that in part is that
it's a great two-star listed building uh
any works that are carried out to a
listed building is a criminal offence
um there is usually the case that
the historic buildings are recorded um
in terms of their detailing at the time
when they are listed
um there is a comprehensive record of
the state of the building at that point
in time
in terms of uh you know it's what it its
original construction would have been
and identifying any latter-day editions
so there is a
there is a detailed records of all the
listed buildings
in the country really yeah um these are
what
uh historic england draw upon um
where they look at these buildings i do
appreciate they can't get to every
single listed building in the country
um given that you know their nationwide
brief
um but it's not a case that they don't
have any sort of idea
even locally within our own services we
have historic records we have
photographs of
a lot of listed buildings particularly
the great two-star listed buildings
because obviously they're within the
sort of high echelons
of of listed buildings uh but really
if anyone carries out any works um uh
and they don't have the
uh the listed building consent rather
than planning permission
um it can normally easily be identified
you know if it's a if it's a building
where you know it would have been
paneled
you know from its historical uh origins
and those are removed
we would normally know that because
there is a record of what the building
would have been
so it's not a sort of blank canvas that
they can go in and do what they want and
we
and we wouldn't know or rather you know
the the listed record wouldn't know
um so um it's obviously just
when we identify when that's been done i
i i don't know obviously the person who
lives there how long they've been there
but some of the additions that have been
added onto the building
do seem to date that quite a bit um you
know
1919 editions um
and various other additions which have
taken place of over the 20th century
so that's just a comment i would make
councillors just in response to that
thank you uh can i ask sorry to come
back on that okay
um thank you for that mr johnson i do
take all that on board
um but we can't always um
sort of litigate for um unscrupal people
and you just don't know where they are
going to appear
um so i would just like to say that
thank you thank you councillor
stilts thank you mr check can i have
some clarity mr johnson you've said that
if anyone does any work on the building
it would be illegal
but didn't we just get told that the
gentleman had
covered some features in the building so
that must mean he's done some work on it
uh right uh you probably called me there
i i don't know the full details of that
work but from what i've read of the
records and probably miss um
staplehurst can sort of assist me here
those were
removing um non-original elements of the
building to reveal
some of the history that's buried within
the building now normally you would
still need listed building consent
and the uh decision to
prosecute i suppose if people to take
you that would be with the local
authorities sort of sort of taking that
out
but i understood from what i've read
that these were investigative works
normally there is a case of
investigation in in terms of
these listed buildings where they are
recorded there was a team
that was working for the um
applicant a recognized team
so that's the only comment i can make at
this stage there has not been
uh any accusation that there's been any
destruction of the original fabric of
the listed building
thank you cancer thank you chair
and could mr johnson please confirm that
the national body
uh responsible for listing and
preservation
is historic england the same body that's
mentioned at 5.2.13.
so councilman you said 5.2.13 yes
is that body the same body that's
responsible for the initial listing
and of the custodians of listed
they may not have been called historic
england back at the time that's a more
that's a newer name obviously they were
english heritage before that
i i couldn't authoritatively say that
they were the same sort of building but
i
sorry um uh
institution but i would imagine that
with the
legislative ability to list buildings
they would be operating under the same
legislative mandate
it was probably unfair of me to
ask mr johnson uh through you chair
perhaps the case officer
could address that
through you chairman it is my
understanding that i think they were
called
english heritage uh previously um but
that they were responsible for the
original listing of the building and do
hold those records
and that is my understanding yes thank
you very much
councillor made and this was called in
by yourself do you want to
uh yeah thank you mr chairman um
i've lived in two grade two listed
buildings
and i know that you can't do virtually
anything and i
have been very surprised that any work
has been carried out
at all of any type investigatory or
otherwise
um however having said that i think
there are some very good points in here
um you know the laying of the pavers for
example in in the
in the in the cellar um it's going to be
on sand which
is great because it will impede natural
moisture as it says in the report
however we then contradict that by
saying there's going to be a ventilation
system
and i'm not quite sure how one marries
the two up
um whether they're i mean i think it's
going it's not actually going to be a
fixed system it's going to be
a movable system i don't know there's
not a
terrible there was i know there was an
update um the secondary the secondary
stairs again
what why this is a home seller sellers
are
you know what they are they're sort of
cold
dark places um window removals
the cart lodge bit on the side which do
we feel
which part of history do we want to keep
and which don't we we shouldn't be
picking and choosing if um
english heritage or historic england i'm
sorry um
have said that you know the cart lodge
is there from 1919 i understand
just after the great war why should we
be actually
altering the street scene that has stood
there since that time
i am concerned about some of the other
small parts of it
but there are some very very good bits
and there is some very good work that is
being done
um i think we then come back to the
proposal that was on the table
to actually do a site visit i think this
may well actually help with this
particular case
but i'll defer to you for further
guidance on that thank you
captain thank you mr chairman i was
hoping that some of the debate might
help me uh make a decision but it's
actually just
made me more certain that we need a site
visit
this is a very very finely balanced one
um
in the whole time that i've been at this
council two years odd now
uh i've only ever known one site visit
um
i believe it's necessary so uh my
proposal was
to do a site visit deferred site visit
and that was seconded by a councillor of
shaughnessy
so um i'd ask that it goes to the vote
please sir
okay um
chairman just going back to the
council's constitution that it does say
that we
do need a reason for the site visit has
to be clearly set out and recorded in
the minutes
okay council morris
thank you chair i would just say that
this is such a finely balanced
decision that we would need to actually
go there and see it the the site visit
would aid
the best decision because as it is now
it's on a knife edge i mean i read some
parts of the report and i'm like yep we
should do this
then i hear and read other parts and i'm
like maybe
you know we're making a mistake so um i
personally
would not be able to vote either way
unless i had a site visit
and i get the feeling that the uh the
the room is full of abstentions as it is
and i'd hope that a site visit would uh
remedy that thank you
um that there are certain aspects being
recorded
there are certain aspects of the
proposals which
um give cause for uh concern
um about damage to the
um the status of the
building as grade 2 star
thank you okay so
recorded vote then presumably recall
invoke police chair
have a second offer counseling
thank you chairman um so members are the
recording this is recorded vote voting
to defer determination pending a site
visit
um as proposed by councillor morris if
you can indicate
for against or abstain and when i call
your name please starting the
councillors deal
four thank you councillor edwards four
councillor against councillor mays
for councillor morris four councillor
nunn
against councillor shawna c four
so chairman that's six four two against
one abstention
thank you so that motion has it um
how do we go about organizing the site
who will do that
mr johnson sorry louise
sherman i'll contact members and the
applicant to arrange that okay thank you
very much through the chair excuse me um
just to let everyone know that um i'm
not getting emails and don't expect to
get any emails any time
soon so uh if i can please be contacted
um
not through emails that i'm not getting
that everyone knows about thank you
okay thank you noted
okay that's so that that that's the
recommendation
sorry that's been um approved
uh
item sixes any items of business there
are none
so i'll close this meeting at nine
seven minutes past nine thank you very
much for coming